okay so let's do a quick review of
lecture seven
um last time we uh finished the
discussion uh and Analysis of uh
gyroscopes specifically we talked about
vibratory mechanical gyroscopes which as
you know they measure the Coriolis
acceleration so let's quickly remind
ourselves of how essentially the
internals of the device are are
constructed so if this is the enclosure
which is a silicon chip you have a proof
Mass inside the device and
it can move into axes right so
that's basically uh the construction of
the device and then in one axis remember
it's actively driven which we call the
primary Axis or the primary mode of the
device so let's say in our case in this
Direction
that's our drive mode
where we basically generate
some drive force and we said that the
drive force is always just a pure
harmonic at a very specific uh chosen
frequency that uh to get the best
sensitivity for the device you choose
that frequency Omega d uh to be or equal
to the resonance frequency of that
harmonic oscillator
in the other axis
which is our sense axis
what happens is that as soon as there is
some angular velocity
Omega
applied to the device the Coriolis
effect will kick in and you get a
coriolis acceleration in the sense
Direction and as we showed the
displacement in the sense direction is
proportional to the angular velocity
Omega so we did the full analysis from
scratch basically derive all the
equations at the end of the day
at the system level what matters is the
sensitivity of the device which is how
much displacement you get in your sense
Axis or sense direction for a given
angular velocity Omega so that ratio is
basically the sensitivity of the device
and after we did the full analysis we
basically came up with this expression
and the high level things as you can see
here proof mass in the numerator
basically tells you larger proof Mass
means more sensitivity we have a few
um basically geometric parameters here
specifically the n h and D these
parameters are tied to the geometry of
the comb Drive capacitive actuator that
the device uses so n is the number of
capacitive plates that you have H is the
height of them and D is the spacing
between the moving and the and the fixed
plates of that cone Drive actuator
v0 squared that's the the voltage or the
voltage amplitude that you apply to your
home drive actuator and then Omega 0
again is the
resonance frequency of the device and
then bxby are the damping factors in the
X and Y directions or in the in the
sense and drive directions which uh
typically they are the same so to in our
analysis we made it General and we're
having like separate dampening factors
but as we said when you do it using
um just a viscous of the gas in a in a
sealed chamber inside the device you
typically get the same dampening factor
in the two directions Okay so
basically
the full analysis of
gyroscopes and again remember that it
really down the hood is an accelerometer
but it's measuring a various it's
designed to measure a very specific type
of acceleration the Coriolis
acceleration which is uh directly
proportional to the angular velocity so
it first finds basically coriolis
acceleration and then with some very
very simple math which is basically just
a scaling
um where linear transformation it
converts that to angular velocity we
also looked at the structure of the
men's devices 1D and and and and and 3D
so by now I hope that for both
accelerometers and gyroscopes you feel
like you you really know these devices
at least the mechanical mems ones inside
and out like from scratch the physics of
it how they're built this signal
analysis the system level analysis on
how you process basically the signals
that you get out of the device the raw
signals to basically convert them to the
accelerations and angular velocities
that you want your sensor to measure
then we started uh basically looking at
the simplest case of robotic perception
which is let's use these two sensors
that we learned about the accelerometer
and the gyroscope and do something
interesting for autonomy which is uh
basically finding the trajectory of a
robot that is is moving which we call
dead reckoning so this is called
inertial navigation and systems that do
that they're called ins's or inertial
navigation systems so the topic of
discussion today is basically how we
uh we do inertial navigation so to do
initial navigation as we said let me go
one slide back maybe just to remind
ourselves or a few slides back so uh so
so this picture here is basically the
problem set up right we have a fixed uh
or a global coordinate system or a
global reference frame
um in which we want to localize the
robot or find the trajectory okay and
that's always like you can choose what
Global reference frame you want to work
with it could be tied to that geometry
like North East down it could be tied to
maybe not the Earth geometry but the
geometry of a building that your robot
is is uh moving at like it could be
aligned with the walls of the building
or something like that but that's
something you choose right you're free
to choose what is your Global reference
frame it's also sometimes called A World
frame right right and then you have your
device the sensor or the ins which I'm
showing with this uh uh blue blue box
here basically and this device
it has no idea what your Global
reference frame is right it only
measures in its own body frame right so
the accelerations that you get for
instance out of an accelerometer it
reports in some XYZ uh coordinates but
these are the XYZ of the device of that
enclosure basically that is is the is
the is the body of the of the sensor so
that we call the body reference frame
here it's shown in blue and it has its
own basically X Y and Z axis
two important things uh your your body
reference frame is uh almost never
aligned with the global reference frame
except for a very specific type of inss
which are called basically a stable
platform those as we talked about have
you know actively driven gimbals that
always align the device with the world
uh coordinates but for what we work with
which are called strap down ins's
there's no active mechanism to align
your sensor with your external frame so
your SB is always going to be different
from your Global frame the transform
between the two is like a 3D rotation
right it could be rotated in in about
the the three XYZ axis so you need to
basically de-rotate the SB the body
frame of reference to align it with the
global frame of reference that's one and
that's the first thing we'll do today
we'll see how you can use your gyroscope
measurements to find that rotation
Matrix and then use that to basically
realign your measurements with your
Global frame also note that SB is time
varying right if your robot is moving
and the sensor is mounted on the robot
at each time step as the robot moves
your body reference frame of the sensor
also moves with the robot right so that
transformation that that basically
derotates your body frame and aligns it
with the global frame it's a Time
varying transform right it's not one
fixed transform except if your robot is
fixed and doesn't move yes then you just
find it once and always use that but
that's not a case of autonomy when
you're talking about autonomous robots
these things are going to be moving in
3D so you need to at each time step find
the right transform to go between the
body frame to the global frame okay
and that's what we're going to do today
and uh as I as I said yesterday so first
we need to formulate the problem
mathematically to be able to solve it
and there's so this the first part is
what we call uh orientation tracking and
orientation tracking is exactly uh what
I just said so find this basically
transform or this rotation that goes uh
basically relates the uh orientation or
the pose of your robot to the
orientation of the global frame and uh
mathematically you can use different
parametrizations for this uh
specifically the three common ones are
Euler angles or you could use what what
is called quaternions or you could use
the so-called Direction cosines there's
there's pros and cons to each of these
in terms of mathematical complexity and
you know intuitiveness and you know the
gotchas that are tied to each of these
in terms of like you know where you need
to be careful with how you do your math
we are going to use Direction cosines
for our analysis that's uh my favorite
one but there's nothing wrong with like
you could you could do the exact same
basically analysis with a different
parametrization but we're going to go
with Direction cosines so when it comes
to Direction cosines
the the way we track the orientation of
the robot or the sensor in this case and
by orientation I mean exactly like that
body reference frame how the XYZ
coordinates of that are oriented uh it
it's going to be with a matrix which we
call C sub G okay so the body
orientation relative to the global
reference frame is represented by a
three by three Matrix C sub G what this
Matrix is is each column of C sub G is
basically one of the unit vectors of
your body frame of reference as
represented in the global frame so your
first column for instance if x sub B is
the X Direction in the body frame of
reference you divide that by its Norm
you get a unit Vector you could call it
X Hat B if you like and and that's the
First Column of your C sub G just like
that your second column is going to be y
Hat B and then you get C Hat B okay so
that's basically how we're going to
represent and if
G is given to you right that means you
exactly know the relationship between
the body reference frame and the global
reference frame because you know that
the three chord and the three axes of
your body frame how they are represented
in the global frame and that's all you
need to know right because it's a 3D
basically World we're working with so
you just need to transform the three
basis vectors of your body frame to the
global frame and then you know the full
transformation basically so specifically
if you want to if a vector is given to
you call that U sub B in the body
reference frame and then you want to
convert that Vector to the global
reference frame all you need to do is
you just multiply that by this
orientation Matrix C that we just
defined okay so very specifically as an
example uh let's let's do something
simple so if you if you just take the
E1
so take your user B to be E1 which is
just the first
identity Vector one zero zero okay so
what does that mean this Vector E1
that's kind of defining your
x-axis in the body reference frame right
like if you are working or tied to the
to the SB frame of reference your x-axis
is just E1 it's one zero zero right now
you multiply that by C sub G what do you
get so C sub G
times E1 of course that extracts the
First Column of c4u so it will give you
X Hat B which is exactly the x-axis of
your body frame as seen in the global
frame so this is actually transforming
as we said from body frame to the global
frame uh what about the other way around
if you want to go from Global frame of
reference to the body frame of reference
you just need to multiply by the inverse
of of your C Matrix right so this is a
rotation Matrix remember it's a 3D
rotation so these matrices just happen
to be uh for geometric reasons uh what
we call hermitian so the inverse of of C
is just its transpose right so and
that's that's basically the identity so
CG transpose is equal to CG inverse
so for with the same Matrix with just a
transposition operation you can invert
it and then you can go from the body
frame to the global frame okay
so all we need to do basically to to do
orientation tracking is we need to find
what this Matrix C sub G is and in this
formulation in this parametrization what
the direction cosines but what makes it
slightly tricky again is that this is a
Time varying Matrix so it's it's really
actually a function of thought so C sub
G of T that we need to find because at
each point in time as the robot moves
that orientation Matrix changes with it
okay sorry so if you have a small time
step delta T
uh what you can do is that you can
formulate a kind of like a Dynamics
equation that relates your C sub G at
time t plus delta T to the C sub G at
previous time step okay so what does
happen at a small time step as assume
that in the time step delta T your robot
moves right so if you look at your
previous pose and the current pose
there's going to be like a small
rotation between the two right there's
also a translation but here we're just
tracking orientation remember right so
by by talking about the orientation we
ignore the translation so if your robot
is like moving in some direction we
ignore that and it's all only the
rotations that that determine uh how C
sub G changes so
relating C sub G at time T to time t
plus delta T there is going to be
a matrix multiplication and this a sub T
is going to be like a tiny rotation
Matrix
which basically determines by how much
did your robot rotate and about which
axis and that determines how much your C
Matrix basically changed right so now to
be able to track c as a function of time
we basically need to solve this equation
but before we can do that we need to
find what this a matrix is right
um in a small time step by how much in
the body frame does your robot basically
uh rotate okay so let's try to find this
aft Matrix together and as you can guess
this is here we're gonna need a
gyroscope data right because we're
talking about rotations in small time
steps so that means that the sensor that
gives you the closest thing to rotation
is the gyroscope which gives you angular
velocities and if you integrate angular
velocities you get basically absolute
angles right so kind of here you should
already guess what's going to happen
something is going to at some point
emerge that is some integral of our
gyroscope uh basically readouts which
are angular velocities
okay so first let's talk about
um
how how rotations basically are
formulated in in 3D coordinates if
you're working with an uh 3D Cartesian
coordinates when we talk about the
rotation it's it's determined by two
things right first you need to define
the axis of rotation and then the angle
of rotation right exactly like when we
were talking about angular velocities
you need the the axis and the velocity
here for rotation same thing you need an
axis and and the amount of rotation
and mathematically uh there is these uh
kind of like very famous uh matrices
that uh basically gives you rotations in
the Cartesian coordinates about the X Y
and Z axes okay uh so for instance if
you rotate a point about the x-axis by
some angle gamma that operation or that
transformation is given by this three by
three uh Matrix that has like cosine
gamma minus sine gamma sine gamma cosine
gamma and then the First Column is one
zero zero this kind of should make sense
because this is a rotation about the
x-axis so if your point is already on
the x-axis and then you rotate it it's
not going to change right so that's why
the First Column is just the the E1
Vector right just like that you can have
rotations about Y and and and Z
basically axes so these are the the the
well-known basically geometric
Transformations that that give us
rotations about the X Y and Z axis so a
general rotation in 3D you can break it
down into basically three rotations
about the three uh uh uh
main coordinates which is the X and the
Y and the Z okay so if you do that for a
general rotation what we can say is that
if you have a general rotation you break
it down to basically three rotations by
a rotation of alpha degrees or radians
in in in Z beta in y and Gamma in x uh
by the way that the numbers you uh yeah
you want you should be careful with your
of course like are you working in
degrees or radians but both work as long
as you know you're doing your math right
uh so so this is like your general
rotation Matrix right so any rotation in
in 3D you can kind of like break it down
to three rotations about X Y and Z with
their corresponding angles
what is extremely important and a source
of you know major errors is that in this
formulation uh order of operations
matter okay so if I change the order of
these Matrix multiplications uh I'm
going to get a different kind of
rotation so these Matrix multiplications
uh they don't do not commute okay so
very simple example
um just to illustrate why the order
matters uh let's say my my three fingers
if my index is the x-axis and the thumb
is the Z so you have x y z okay I'm
going to do two rotations by 90 degrees
starting let's say the vector we are
working with is already on on the x-axis
so it's pointing in in my in the
direction of my index finger now I'm
going to do two rotations 90 degrees
about x and z axis okay so in the in the
first one I'm going to rotate about Z
first and then about X so rotate about Z
that's not where I'm pointing at 90
degrees and then I'm going to rotate
about X it's going to point up right so
that's the final direction that we
landed okay 90 degrees 90 degrees ZX
okay that's experiment one now let's
change the order of applying the
rotations I start with X I'm going to
rotate about X first well nothing
changes right it's still pointing in the
same direction so X and then you do your
Z and now it's going to be pointing left
see so change the order you you end up
with different orientation so super
important if you're doing
going with this parametrization and the
Cartesian coordinates order of
operations matter okay
all right so with that now we can kind
of start basically uh doing our full
analysis so what we are doing again we
want to track very small rotations of
the body of this of the sensor or the
robot in small time increments so what
happens is
um
your body frame basically rotates by
small angles about X Y and Z directions
and those angles we can directly get
them from our gyroscope readout so for
instance rotation about XB and this B is
very very important right so we're
talking right now in the body reference
frame of the of the sensor or the robot
so rotation about X which is called rho
that angle Delta Phi is is equal to the
angular velocity that the gyroscope is
measuring about the x-axis times delta T
right so that's that's just basically
you multiply your velocity by a small
time Delta that gives you the Delta
angle basically in a small time step
just like that your pitch which is
rotation about the y-axis of the body is
given by the angular velocity about that
axis times delta T and rotation about Z
is given by angular velocity about the
z-axis times delta T right so that's
simple now we also will know what the
rotation matrices look like as a
function of the angle so now we can
write a rotation Matrix for our role
basically so rotation about X by by some
angle data Delta Theta is given by
this Matrix this is the same thing we
saw before I've just plugged in Delta
Theta for my rotation angle but here we
can do a simplification because we're
working with very small time steps delta
T that means the angles are also very
small right Delta Theta is Delta Phi is
is small and we can make a small angle
approximation what is that that means
the cosine of your angle is is
approximately one and the sine of the
angle is approximately equal to Delta
Phi itself here in this approximation
you have to work in radians right this
this approximation is in radians not in
degree so don't plug in numbers and
degrees in here right these are in
radians so that's just a small or you
know this this is coming from like the
if you take the Taylor series
approximation of a sine function and
just keep the first term basically
that's what what you get okay so this is
now our rotation Matrix that gives us
the role in a very small
time step in the body frame of reference
for very small angles okay just like
that we can also get the rotation Matrix
for pitch and for yaw and again for all
of them you make the small angle
approximation and you're left with you
you basically get these matrices which
have Delta Theta and Delta Psi in them
okay
all good
all right so now we want to get the
general 3D Matrix of rotation right so
we have to multiply these three
but here's the issue I just told you
when you want to multiply the order of
operations matter right
um so in what order are we going to
apply these three matrices one very nice
thing that happens here which is part of
the reason why I like this formulation
of Direction cosines is that although
generally
the order of of matrix multiplication
for rotations matter when you work with
small angles it doesn't matter because
second order terms basically become
almost zero and now with when as long as
you're working with these matrices with
very small angles you can apply
rotations in in any order and you get
the exact same result that's that's part
of the beauty of this parametrization
basically so now this Matrix a t that we
were looking for which we said is a
small rotation Matrix over a Time step
delta T we just write it as the
multiplication of our role our yaw our
pitch and our role
matrices right those three rotation
matrices and you can multiply them in
any order you like and you get this
Matrix basically
um
very simple so
um diagonal entries as you see are all
one and then off diagonals are basically
small angles and corresponding to pitch
yaw and row of of the body basically in
a small time uh Delta so R A then we can
write it as the identity Matrix so the
identity gives you basically this
diagonal entity entries that are all one
plus Matrix we call Delta Psi and
there's a PSI is basically the Matrix
which has all these small angles in it
right and these are small angles
remember they are directly related to
the readouts of our gyroscope so the
angular velocities that basically our
gyroscope measures those directly
determine these angles so for instance
our Delta Psi is just angular velocity
about the z-axis
times delta T right or Delta Phi is just
Omega BX which is angular velocity about
the x-axis times delta T right so here
we have the full parametrization and
directly we can take the gyroscope uh uh
measurements and populate this this
Matrix Delta Psi you add identity to it
and you find your your a sub T okay
remember that as as we did this matrix
multiplication
um and and that's also why the order of
operations here doesn't matter is
because we assume the second order terms
which is the multiplication of two small
angles is almost almost equal to zero so
that's basically mathematically why it
turns out that when you work with small
angles the order of operations don't
matter because these
basically the order of operations
goes into the second order terms which
are almost zero for for very small
angles okay
so now we have found our a
right and we know how is directly
related to gyroscope measurements and we
can go back to the original equation
that we had for how our orientation
Matrix C changes over time and then we
can try to solve that to find
orientation as a function of time so
let's do that
um now we are doing proper orientation
tracking right we start with looking at
the time derivative of CG right that's
how C changes over time and by
definition it's just basically C at time
t plus delta T minus C of T over delta T
and we take the limit of that as delta T
goes to zero right so let's do that we
plug in what we just found for C of t
plus delta T we just showed that that is
equal to this Matrix a of T times C
right
and also a itself we found that you can
write it a as identity plus this Matrix
Delta Psi so plug that in and now what
happens is that the these two terms
cancel right the identity and this minus
CG cancel out and uh what you're left
with is basically just limit of delta T
going to zero Delta Psi times CG over
delta T right so you can factor out your
CG basically out of the limit and you're
just left with the limit of Delta Psi
over delta T as delta T goes to zero and
this is a very very simple limit to
calculate because if we
um
basically remember what Delta Psi was it
was this Matrix Omega times delta T
right like the entries of Delta Psi
where the angular velocities multiplied
by the Delta T's right so as you divide
by that all the Delta T's basically go
away then your limit basically becomes
just this this Matrix we call Omega
times CG
and Omega is a matrix of just the
gyroscope readouts it only has the
angular velocities in it very very very
simple right so at the end of the day
what we have is CG dot equals Omega
times CG
it's a simple Dynamics equation the only
thing that complicates it a little bit
is as you see here this Omega itself is
a function of time so the proper way of
like if we want to be explicit about it
it's Omega t
times CG right because the angular
velocities can change over time make
that makes this Matrix a function of
time nevertheless it's a first order
time independent time dependent Dynamics
equation
and we can solve that if we solve that
then we have our c as a function of time
and then we know and it's also it's
going to be a function of time and it's
going to be a function of
gyroscope readouts there's nothing else
in this equation right like all the
readouts are known so so then we can do
proper orientation tracking so let's do
that
we start with this equation and there is
an analytical solution for for this you
might remember it from your your
calculus course but basically uh with
this first order uh equation the
solution is given by this your CG of T
is the exponential of the integral of
Omega from zero to T times C 0. so c0 is
kind of like your initial orientation or
the initial condition that you start at
at time zero and you need to know that
somehow so that could be either like
assumed if you're just doing relative
tracking or that could be learned from
visual cues or maybe from some other
sensor tells you oh you're starting at
this pose or orientation at time zero so
you somehow know that or maybe you have
like a digital compass that tells you
the orientation at Time Zero or
something like that and then you
basically integrate uh this Matrix Omega
which which is the Matrix of your
gyroscope readouts
and then you take the exponential of it
multiply that by your initial
orientation and that that gives you your
orientation Matrix at time t Okay a
couple of things to note well first as
we guessed before we did any math it
turned out that you need to integrate
your gyroscope measurements
to track orientation and that should
make complete sense right these are
angular velocities you integrate angular
velocities that should somehow give you
absolute velocities but uh
important thing is is basically you
integrate your Omega but then you take
the the exponential of it right so it's
e to the integral of Omega and this here
this is a matrix exponential right
because your Omega is a three by three
Matrix you integrate that you get a
three by three Matrix so this is a
matrix exponential
it's not a scalar exponential
big deal but it's just uh
because our notation is
I spell this right exponential yeah I
think so
um because our notation is overloaded I
I just want to point that out that this
is going to be a matrix exponential
which is perfectly fine
um
especially for instance when you're when
you're doing
um uh your your your your algorithms or
DSP in a uh on a computer for instance
most modern libraries have the support
for a matrix exponentials but if you're
doing things on like a small embedded
processor doing Matrix exponentials can
be very expensive so in a few minutes
we're going to find a a better
formulation for this which is
computationally much more efficient but
before that there's another thing which
is our reader so this this was assuming
that so this is like we're doing like a
continuous time derivation here right
like our integrals or continuous and all
that but the actual measurements uh come
discreetly right like your your sensors
gives you measurements at some rate they
don't continuously you know as a
function of time give you read that so
you can get I don't know a good
gyroscope might give you measurements a
few hundred Hertz 400 800 maybe a
kilohertz so you get like a thousand
measurements per second so you get
discrete time discretized measurements
over over time oh measurements over
discretized time
um
uh so so we have to basically solve this
integral discreetly right um You can
continuously integrate it so let's do
that it actually becomes a lot simpler
if you do it that way so what we do then
uh let's just uh come with a solver that
goes step by step so one step at a time
you basically update your orientation as
a new measurement come in comes in you
just update uh your orientation uh
according to the measurement so
basically we are now just looking at one
time Step at delta T okay so you're
going one step forward in time and you
just want to update your orientation
Matrix C we still use the same solution
we found so that should be equal to the
integral of of Omega just over uh the
time step so we go from T to t plus
delta T that's just one step okay and
you multiply that by your previous
orientation Matrix okay
um so so this here basically
is um I'm kind of uh like your your your
aft basically that that that we had we
were just doing like one uh time
increment so if you just
from T to t plus delta T you assume that
Omega is is constant over that tiny time
step so that Matrix exponential just
becomes e to the Omega T times uh uh
times delta T and Omega T times delta T
remember that's that's that
basically PSI of t uh uh or Delta Psi of
T Matrix that we had defined before so
in small time increments your update
equation is just take your previous
orientation Matrix multiply it by e to
the Delta Psi okay and that's how you
discretely basically track your
orientation and uh what is e to the
double side or just generally a matrix
exponential it's given by this Taylor
series expansion so you start from
Identity plus Delta Psi Delta Psi
squared over 2 factorial so it's an
infinite series basically
um that that that gives you them it's
it's the same as a scalar exponentials
basically but remember that this guy
Delta Psi is a three by three Matrix
here okay so this is now perfectly fine
like with this equation and I'm just
going to rewrite it here CAG of t plus
delta T or if you want to work with
indices this could be your like n plus 1
time index equals e to the Delta Psi
at n
times CG at n
right that's your update equation I'm
just going to make those brackets n plus
1. so that's our update equation this is
perfectly fine right like if on any
modern you know compute platform you can
do this uh your your samples of readouts
of the of the IMU come or of the of the
gyroscope come one at a time you you
basically use them to build this Delta
Psi Matrix at time n you take the Matrix
exponential multiply that by your
previous orientation Matrix and then you
get the new one and that works perfectly
fine however as I said in uh in when you
don't have a lot of compute resources
doing
something like an infinite series
becomes a very uh challenging because
you don't have you know access to say a
modern CPU or a GPU that can do this
very very fast for you because of that
it really helps if we can find a more
mathematically efficient way of of
finding this Matrix exponential and it
turns out that it there is a beautiful
derivation that that finds a much much
more efficient way of calculating that a
matrix exponential with no
approximations so here we're going to do
that so what what we do is uh we Define
an auxiliary variable we call that rho
of T and that's just the norm of Omega B
times delta T what is Omega B Omega B is
the vector in R3 that is the three
readouts of your
gyroscope right so so it's basically
your uh
Omega X Omega y Omega Z
Vector in in SB so in the body reference
frame times delta T so that's our three
Vector you'd get the norm of that you
get rho so row is a scalar valued
function
and then with that definition it turns
out that if you find the the third power
of Delta Psi it just becomes equal to
negative rho squared times Delta Psi
itself right and here this is just pure
math like you can start with actually
like plugging everything into here I'm
I'm not going to do it here because it's
boring and it gets a bit messy there's
too many terms in the third power but if
you actually are patient enough to do
this and go simplify and see how many
terms cancel out it actually turns out
that there's this very nice relationship
between the third power of this Matrix
Delta Psi and its first power so with
that then if we start with basically
this final infinite series
or the one on top everything that is a
uh an an odd power of Delta Psi you can
write it as
a multiple of Delta Psi itself and
everything that is an even power becomes
a multiple of Delta Psi squared so if
you do that for all the odd and even
terms then you get something like this a
lot of so so you just get your identity
plus something which is just a function
of rho times Delta Psi plus another
infinite series which is just a function
of rho times Delta Psi squared right now
if you carefully inspect these infinite
Series in row they're very closely
related to the sine and cosine Taylor
series expansions so specifically the
first one this this infinite series is
just sine row over rho and the second
one turns out to be just 1 minus cosine
over rho squared and these are just
purely from the Taylor series expansions
of sine and cosine functions so you see
now we have something really really
beautiful let's go to the next slide
look at it together so this guy here
which is just the sum of three terms the
first one is Identity the second one is
just this sine rho over rho times Delta
Psi and the third one is one minus
cosine over rho Square Delta Psi squared
this is exactly equal to e to the Delta
Psi
term that or Delta Psi of T that we have
and again there's no approximations here
so so this expression is exact and for
this most systems that run on small
embedded processors actually instead of
doing the actual Matrix exponential they
just use this formula because it's much
much much more efficient as you can see
like instead of an infinite sum it's
just three terms you just need sine and
cosine functions which are many
efficient ways of of uh calculating them
and then you just need Delta Psi and
Delta Psi squared okay so so that's how
it's done and what is Delta side let's
just remind ourselves that's just a
matrix that has our gyroscope readouts
the omegas times delta T
and the Omega is the Omega BX b y uh and
and b z are just the three readouts that
the gyroscope provides so at each time
step basically you get a new omega B
Vector from the gyroscope right three
new measurements three new angular
velocities measured you plug them into
this you build your Delta Psi Matrix
right and then you plug Delta Psi into
your update equation
you know do the sine and cosine and
everything in the parentheses multiply
that by your previous orientation Matrix
and that gives you your new orientation
Matrix you start of course with CG at
time 0 which as I said you should assume
sometimes it's given to you sometimes a
different sensor is provide provides it
but this needs to be known or assumed
and then over time you just multiply
that by this update Matrix and then
that's how you do orientation tracking
any questions
yes just to climate connections this is
like the analytical solution of how you
can take an exponent so the reason why
we use this equation is that the taking
the x is cheaper to take the signs and
cosines than they correct so the reason
that we work with uh this equation again
like if you're working on your computer
and you know you're just doing
experiments by all means just do the
Matrix exponential why go through the
trouble of you know implementing this
just do that works perfectly fine but if
you're working in an application where
your resource constraint on your on your
compute you need very low latency you
know fast uh calculations then you use
this and exactly asham said it's much
cheaper and easier to find sine and
cosine functions than
basically a infinite series of a matrix
exponential that that Series has lots of
Matrix multiplications in it and Matrix
multiplications are generally expensive
to compute Sines and cosines there is
either you can have a lookup table for
it but you can just save the values of
sine and cosines discretize it and just
use a lookup table then it's basically
free I mean it takes up memory but it
doesn't take up any compute or if you
want to compute them in real time
they're very efficient algorithm times
approximate algorithms of course to give
you Sines and cosines I think a good one
is called
I can't remember the name but there's a
famous one that is used a lot in
embedded software engineering
okay so yes
cosine of the Matrix is it just element
wise oh the rule remember is is a scalar
so the question was sine and cosine of a
matrix so this row was just uh oh I'm
actually it's it's here the row is the
norm of a vector so it's just a scalar
value so these are regular you know sine
and cosines of of a number basically in
here and and that's again why
um it's it's fast and efficient to to
compute those okay
um
so we have done orientation tracking we
haven't quite done you know our our uh
localization or dead reckoning but this
was the difficult part of it the rest is
easy because as you said if you know the
orientation now what you do is this is
just this C is just a rotation Matrix at
the end of the day so you apply that to
your accelerometer readouts and that
rotates them back from body reference
frame to the global reference frame and
then you just integrate your
accelerometer readouts you go from
acceleration to Velocity and from
velocity to uh position as as we'll do
next but note that
as we are doing this process
our measurements were both accelerometer
and gyroscope these are not perfect as
you know there's biases and there's
noise in the measurements at the very
least if it's not well calibrated you
can have you know crosstalk and other
things but at the even in the best case
you have a little bit of bias and and
and and some noise and what happens is
as you integrate these measurements
uh of course you will be integrating
your bias and bias is is like a fixed
Vector so as you integrate that that
leads to an error that will grow
linearly with time
right remember if you had this integral
of Omega Tau D Tau and Omega has the
angular velocities in it and if angular
velocities have biases you integrate the
bias as part of that process and then
you have your noise terms also in the
readouts and the noises because these
are basically zero mean random variables
they show up as some orientation random
walk right so here's one example
um so we're working with a simple case
the the true angular velocity of the
ground truth in this case was just uh
0.1 degrees per second of yaw so that's
rotation about the z-axis okay but the
sensor we were working with it had some
bias and it has it had some noise with
that spectral density and a bandwidth of
one kilohertz so as you integrate that
and you find PSI of T which is the the
angle between the the body x-axis this
and the global x-axis uh as you expect
if it's rotating at a constant angular
velocity that means the angle should
just vary linearly with time and that's
your ground truth the blue curve here is
the ground truth but that what you
actually track with the algorithm we
just described is the red so as you see
there's there's a little bit of Jitter
on the red so that's the effect of noise
that's a little bit of you know the the
noise added and then the bias causes
this this error to grow linearly with
time you see this Gap is becoming larger
and larger as the as the time uh goes so
you just start to drift away and that's
a big problem with pure inertial uh uh
navigation because biases always
cause this drift over time and that's a
very well known issue
okay
now let's talk about position tracking
so we did orientation tracking now we're
going to use our orientation tracking to
do position tracking with this drop down
ins and Global reference frame this is
very easy because what the accelerometer
readouts are it gives you accelerations
in the x y z coordinates of the body
right so it gives you a a ABX a b y and
ABC these are the three accelerations in
the body reference frame and all you
need to do is to transform it to the
global reference frame subtract the
gravity component and integrate right
how do we transform to the global
reference frame we use our C sub G
Matrix that we just learned how to find
from gyroscope measurements right and we
we know that the the way the CG works it
transforms vectors from body reference
frame to Global reference frame it's a
rotation Matrix right so if you multiply
your uh your a in the
body frame by CG at time T it gives you
the a in the global reference frame
right so we do that first at every time
step and then um we also need to
subtract the gravity component that's a
fixed Vector that you just subtract we
call it g sub G and so what you do is
that after transforming your a to the
global frame you subtract the gravity
component from it and then you integrate
that
and add your initial velocity to it that
gives you your velocity at time t
and then to find position you integrate
your velocity from time 0 to T and add
your initial position to it and that
gives you your position at time T so
this is now we're doing full that
Reckoning again there's two initial
conditions that you need to somehow know
which is your initial velocity and
initial position need to be known as the
case of orientation you can either
assume those if you're just doing
relative uh position tracking if you're
doing absolute they should be given to
you from a different sensor so maybe
from your GPS was it for instance it
gives you your absolute position and
absolute velocity at time zero and then
you use that as the initial condition
for your basically position tracking
with with the ins one thing to note
about this
gravity component that you're
subtracting it of course needs to be the
gravity in the environment that you're
working with so on Earth we know like
the gravity is 9.8 meters per second
squared and we use that it's it needs to
be the gravity Vector so it should be
pointing to the right direction
basically but if you're doing position
tracking with ins on Mars you should
subtract of course the Mars gravity
component so don't hard code the Earth
value in your codes if you're working on
a on a Mars Rover basically
Okay so
again
again form instead of doing continuous
integrals which is even simpler so you
just have a bunch of update equations
basically to track velocity and position
and the way it works is at every time
step
you basically maybe there's one more
equation I should have have written here
I'm going to just add it up up there the
first thing you do is you transform your
acceleration from
a global frame
to the body frame sorry from the body
frame to the global frame so a b is the
direct readout of the accelerometer
multiply that by your your orientation
Matrix to convert it to the global frame
and then once you have a at time T in
the global frame subtract the gravity
component multiply that by your time
step right and that gives you your Delta
velocity added to your velocity at the
previous time step and that gives you
the velocity at the next time step and
then you use that velocity times delta T
and add that to your position at the
previous time and that gives you the
position in the new time notice that
again overloaded notation so all these
are are three vectors right your
acceleration the a is a vector the V is
a vector and the p is a vector these are
all in general there are three if you're
just doing stuff in t 2D these are
vectors in R2 but generally these are R2
right so your updated equation you apply
them every time a new accelerometer
readout becomes available so as your new
readouts come in you just update your
position and velocity accordingly and
that's complete basically that Reckoning
again important to note is that now we
are essentially doing a little bit of
Sensor Fusion right because in the in
the in the previous slide this c g
Matrix this is coming from gyro
and the a is coming from accelerometer
right so this is like the simplest case
of like using two sensors to do
something interesting with it but that
means there's now contributions from the
bias and and noise of both sensors in
here so they both contribute and the way
they contribute is kind of interesting
because what happens from the Gyros
contribution uh the bias and the noise
it causes errors in the orientation
right and that c c Matrix and what
happens is that we use that c to
transform our accelerations from body
reference frame to the global reference
frame right so that bias and noise
causes an error in that transformation
which means now your accelerations are
not exactly in the global frame there is
a little bit of error in that so the
accelerations are going to be
incorrectly transformed to the global
reference frame which means also that
the gravity component is not correctly
subtracted because you always assume
your gravity component according to the
the geometry of the fixed frame and then
you subtract that if your accelerations
are not in the proper frame there's
going to be a little bit of residual
basically gravity component and then you
integrate those accelerations in the
wrong directions right so that's a what
what happens the contribution of Gyro
basically a bias and noise and then the
accelerometer readouts themselves have
have their own bias and noise right
those are not perfect and what happens
there is that you start from an
acceleration which has some bias and
some noise and you're double integrating
right because you integrate once we go
from acceleration to Velocity and then
you integrate again from velocity to
position so a fixed bias in acceleration
you integrate it twice it gives you a
quadratic error in position so errors
can really really blow up if you just
purely do
orientation tracking with inss or Imus
over long periods of time very important
to know so you get position errors
growing quadratically in time and then
you double integrate your noise that
just gives you some random walk on top
of your basically position tracking
in terms of like which of these two
contributions is is uh kind of like
worse than the other usually Gyros
contribution
is is the bigger effect than
accelerometer although from what I said
that like these errors become quadratic
the bias of the accelerometer still it
turns out gyro bias has that go makes
its way into the orientation tracking
has a bigger effect on the overall error
of our dead reckoning
um so for instance if you have a tilt
error of just
0.05 degrees I mean it's really not much
right you would think I mean this is
nothing
with that much tilt error if you just uh
integrate it for 30 seconds again not a
lot of time you're going to end up with
close to 8 meters of of position error
which could be catastrophic depending on
the application okay
so
that's uh you should be very aware of
you know these
um basically limitations as you as
you're as you're using those those
techniques and you should always do your
full analysis
um according to the sensors that you've
picked for your application look at
their data sheet look at the BIOS look
at the noise plug in the numbers do a
simulation and make sure like the
whatever area you end up with in the
worst case is like within the margin of
tolerance for your application otherwise
very very bad things could happen here's
an example of a 2d dead reckoning so we
are
um basically the the ground truth
velocities and accelerations angular
velocities and accelerations are given
here they're fixed uh just
for Simplicity I just assumed like it
fixed the yaw rate and some fixed
accelerations in in X and Y directions
of the body reference frame and some
bias values and some noise values so
basically we plug everything in we
assume we start with an orientation
that's aligned to the global frame and
at zero velocity and at the origin just
to make this simulation simpler and then
you do a 2d position tracking or dead
reckoning as we call it so you start at
the origin at Time Zero
and the blue curve gives you the the
ground truth basically trajectory after
100 seconds
um so and it moves fast right like it's
it's already moved more than a couple of
kilometers basically and then the red uh
gives you your basically what we get out
of our ins tracking algorithm that
Reckoning and and you see
um there is after 100 seconds in this
case there's already quite a bit of
error I mean if you look at the skills
here this is a few hundred meters
probably right like one to two hundred
meters probably uh
which is a lot for any applications I
would say but again I I mean this I'm
not trying to say this never works these
these numbers are are probably a bit bit
exaggerated
but for this reason that there's always
error in a purely inertial navigation uh
in any real system uh you would always
want to use other sensors and fuse them
into how you do your orientation
tracking the simplest one which is very
very common these days is use GPS
because GPS as we know it gives you
absolute position so there is no bias in
GPS measurements there's noise there's
quite a bit of noise it could be you
know up to a couple meters or more off
but there is no bias and that's that's
very important so you can bring in your
GPS measurements and it gives you
velocity also position and velocity and
and somehow through a signal processing
technique like say call man filtering
for instance you can fuse in your
odometry that you're getting from
accelerometer and Gyros and also fuse
that with your GPS measurements so what
happens is that GPS measurement come in
slowly there's a it's a slower update
rate than Imus but they don't have any
bias in them right IMU measurements come
much faster but there's bias so in that
sense they are complementary yeah or if
you remember uh
just when we started the topic of of
Imus I told you like when it comes to
localization there's position fixing and
there's debt Reckoning GPS does position
fixing it doesn't do debt Reckoning
right so it gives you unbiased estimates
of of your position so you can kind of
see if you kind of like
you should be able to do much much
better than this and and that actually
is how it's done you can these days by
integrated devices that have an ins and
a GPS receiver already integrated with
some signal processing engine that does
diffusion for you these are called ins
gnss
receivers that you plug in basically a
small GPS antenna to it and it does the
fusion between the GPS and IMU uh
there's even better ways of doing it you
can mix it in with uh visual
odometry or or positioning and a very
interesting common technique genuine
which is a big research field it's
called Vio or visual inertial odometry
so then you mix in some way of you know
estimating velocity and eventually
position from visual cues coming from
cameras or lidars or Radars with the
inertial techniques that we just talked
about and then you can almost completely
eliminate these error effects that grow
over time so with with Sensor Fusion
techniques done right you can get almost
perfect basically localization in many
applications the cost of courses you
need more sensors and you need more
complex
algorithms to do it but it can be done
and it works works beautifully bottom
line is there's a lot you can do with
inertial sensors but they also have very
significant limitations
um they're used almost always but also
almost always they're mixed in some way
or short with other sensors to
compensate these limitations any
questions yes
would you explain the units of the noise
yes
great great question uh the units of the
noise
um these are confusing I agree uh so
which one because they're both confusing
right like let's look at the let's look
at the gyro
uh so the question is what what the hell
is that the units like 1 over square
root of seconds it's actually explained
in that part of the the notes which uh I
I skipped over where we derived the the
noise power uh Power Spectrum but uh the
way you actually without going into the
details if you read that part it's it's
really explained there but super high
level the way this makes sense is that
it's a it's it's a power spectral
density okay so you want to like
integrate it over over some bandwidth
right and then that bandwidth is is is
uh going to be uh basically in in units
of Hertz right and what you want to get
after you you integrate it should be in
units of one over seconds right so
that's that's the angular velocity or
radians over over per second right uh so
so one way that you you can do that and
then as part of the process sometimes
instead of reporting because there's
when you
re when you find a power spectral
density you essentially are looking at
the square of the magnitude of an fft to
go to convert it to power units right
but the confusing thing that some people
some data sheets actually do is that
well although essentially you should you
should do the squaring to find your
power spectral density but then they
actually report the square root of it
instead of reporting the square and
that's where this little square root
over of seconds comes from so it's you
have something that is like a like a
power Spectrum with with units of one
over a second over Hertz and then you
take the the square root of that and
that's that's where the the square root
actually comes from I know I my my
explanation was probably even more
confusing than uh than what I was hoping
to to get to but if you really read that
few pages in the in the notes where we
derived this that the units become very
clear because you have to see the math
and then it becomes clear where the
units are this same here uh the the the
the micro G per root Hertz the the
square root is again comes from that
conversion from the absolute value of
the fft and the squaring that is
involved to make it a power Spectrum
basically
um but uh yeah these are I really really
don't like these units I find them
myself confusing but it's for some
reason it's the industry standard that
if you look at any data sheet they
um yeah they they report it in this way
okay so uh
now we can start the next chapter which
is going to be uh
about sound navigation and ranging or
sonar okay before we uh
start the discussion of sonar itself I
want to talk a little bit about robotic
mapping and because essentially the next
uh four chapters of uh of the course is
going to be about sensors that are used
in robotic mapping okay IMU and GPS
those are used for
localization and odometry as we know
right so again just to remind ourselves
where we started we know that to do
navigation requires three things right
you require a map you also need to
localize yourself in the map and you
also need to know how you're moving
which means you need to do odometry the
two sensors we have learned about so far
which is the GPS and the IMU they help
with these two right so with IMU you can
do localization for instance as we just
talked about using uh that Reckoning it
also
directly gives you odometry right it
gives the accelerations velocities
angular velocities same for GPS it
localizes you and it does some limited
odometry also but the none of these do
anything regarding to mapping right if
you don't have a map you really can't
localize yourself even if you have
perfect odometry and localization so now
we're going to start talking about about
mapping okay so what is mapping it's a
process of basically you sense your
environment and you construct either a
two-dimensional or a three-dimensional
map that shows you the static and
dynamic objects around you right so it's
kind of like a visual representation of
of the environment around you and when
it comes to map there's two different
ways that mapping is done
one is called offline mapping and
offline maps are basically pre-recorded
Maps like you open your your Google Map
basically and there is a pre-recorded
map in there right
um that that you can look at and and you
can use so so those are offline maps
there's also online or live mapping and
these are real-time generated so your
robot basically uses the sensors that it
has on board and in real time it Maps
out what the environment around it is
and each of these types of mapping as
its pros and cons basically as we'll see
but uh it's important to note that in
many applications both are actually used
so the the the robots will have some
offline map and then they also do some
live mapping
um
the the most obvious reason why you
always need the live mapping is that
offline maps they don't give you for
instance Dynamic Targets in the scene
like if you look at your Google Map you
can't just drive by looking at the
Google Map because first it's course and
it's not you know super high resolution
but even if it was it doesn't show you
the cars on the street or the
pedestrians or the you know other other
things that are dynamically moving right
and you need to know that and those you
need to measure in real time of course
so you always need some level of of live
mapping
um so here's is is uh just like one uh
illustration of of uh a map that uh kind
of like an autonomous vehicle has has
generated so this is like a 3D map from
a lidar and in you know it shows all the
the static parts of the scene like the
road and the building structures and
there's also you know the pedestrians
and cars and other things the bounding
boxes here that's not part of the
mapping so there's like on the map they
have run some perception algorithm and
then they have done some classification
of you know
um pedestrians and cars and things like
that so the bounding boxes are
technically not not part of the map
okay so let's talk a little more about
this idea of offline and and online
mapping starting with offline maps
there's there's two very distinct types
of offline maps and these they're called
high definition maps and standard
definition Maps starting with the
standard definition Maps that's exactly
what you get for instance from your
Google Maps or Apple Maps or you know
these these uh you know online uh
navigation maps that are available
um
they're extremely useful they show you
no roads and you know buildings and
things like that but they're not super
high resolution and they don't show you
typically you know the the fine
structures in the scene or anything like
that then there's HD Maps which here's a
screenshot of and these are like super
super high resolution like if you look
at this this map here it even shows you
you know the the the poles of you know
for different traffic signs and things
like that all the structure in the trees
and the buildings are very visible it
even shows you you know the exact lanes
and directions of the road so this is
one that is generated for autonomous
driving of course but it has a lot more
detail than a standard definition map
now
um I am personally and and this is not
like a very scientific opinion but I'm
personally not a big fan of hdmaps so
it's it's a huge topic of debates
especially when it comes to autonomous
driving that like should you or should
autonomous Drive Drive autonomous
vehicles use hdmaps or not and it's it's
a big debate of course it helps a lot if
you have these high definition maps I
mean you can do a lot with them when it
comes to localization but these are very
very expensive to generate as you can
imagine you need you know to in very
high detail map how the entire cities
basically it's not on a scalable
operation and the maps become obsolete
like if there's construction going out
on and in a couple of months you know
they they change the road or the
building your your map is is not valid
or part of it is not valid for those
Reasons I'm not a big fan of HD Maps I
think it's it's convenient but but it's
not scalable for you know uh for
autonomy globally but I should also say
that
almost all the autonomous vehicle demos
we see on the roads today like if you go
to San Francisco and you know use any of
the available Services they are using
hdmaps heavily right
um but uh the the only I think one of
the the
almost like you know autonomous uh
products out there that as far as I know
does not use uh hdmaps is Tesla I don't
think Tesla uses htmas it it just live
Maps the environment that the vehicle
maybe they use SD Maps too I mean I'm
sure they use SD Maps but not HTML SC
maps are cheap they're already available
right like Google or Apple Maps or other
other map applications they're already
globally available they can be done much
cheaper you typically use satellites you
know to map out the Earth and and and
those are uh
very easy to use so that's about offline
maps and then when it comes to live
mapping
um
uh the live maps are typically much
sparser than uh
um than the offline maps because again
these are live generated so you're
getting like frames of data from uh your
your sensor or points of data from from
your sensor and you're using those to in
real time and by real time I mean in
very short time scales you have
typically like tens of milliseconds to
to map the environment around you
and and for that reason there's very
limited information available to the
robot to do live mapping so typically
when you look at a live map they're
called Point clouds because they're just
like a collection of points in two or or
3D and they're generally much sparser
here we're looking at a live map from a
radar
this was measured in Redwood City and
just to give context I've I've shown the
uh the the offline SD map from from
Google Maps I think of the exact same
scene so because if you just look at the
the radar 2D Point Cloud it might not
make a lot of sense but from here for
instance you see like this L-shaped
structure here that's actually this
building
um this trapezoidal looking thing that's
actually the wall here and there's
actually fences around the this parking
lot so that's why the the radar is
actually detecting defenses are metallic
as we'll see Radars are good at
detecting metallic things this angle
structure here is actually this building
and there's the stuff here those are
cars I mean these are not
captured at the same time but as you see
there's always like Cars part on the
side of the street so that's that's
where you are and and you have the two
roads and the cross section basically on
the two sorry so so it's it's useful I
mean the point here is that but yes it's
very sparse but because it's generated
live and it also you know gives you the
details of all the dynamic assets of in
the scene live maps are going to be very
useful this one again is 2D so it only
has Azimuth uh resolution and elevation
everything is flattened out it's kind of
like gives you a bird's eye view if you
will of the scene but you can also have
a 3D Point clouds or live Maps so here's
one from a velodyne lidar for instance
generated so again you have your ego
vehicle in the center and there was a
lidar mounted on top of it and these
round things that you see these are kind
of like the scanning lines of the lidar
we'll talk in in painful detail about
all this in a couple of weeks so don't
worry right now just visually I want you
to kind of get a feel for uh what these
live Maps look like it's 3D it's live
but it is sparse right it's not as dense
as I get a a offline HD map still
extremely extremely useful for uh for
autonomy applications
now
uh when it comes to especially live
mapping and and you you talk with
different people working in robotics
um sometimes when when you say map
people think of something either just
offline maps or they think of something
which is which is called a uh a slam uh
output that I'm going to show you in a
second
for me I like to think of all of these
as Maps because they are different ways
of just mapping the environment around
you some of them are generated offline
some of them are generated live the live
ones are typically sparse but you know
they give you live information and more
useful for autonomy but just why not if
you show this to some person and call it
a map and they might say oh but this is
just a point Cloud I mean
don't don't even you know debate with
them let them call it what they want but
these are maps of of the environment but
just note that like people like to Now
call these just uh just point clouds or
images sometimes of of the environment
and then when you say Maps they just
think of offline maps for us these are
all maps there's different types of it
offline online and then there's
different flavors of online mapping uh
you can generate live maps that are very
very dense using a technique which is
called simultaneous localization and
mapping and here is a a 3D map of our
own campus actually here you see the
Hoover Tower this is looking into the
main quad and the oval is over here and
this is uh
is this called Jane Stanford Road now
yes
um
so this is one I did four years ago with
a with a lidar but so as you see this is
much denser right compared to the
previous like this one where it's like
on the road you get like big gaps for
instance between the lighter scan lines
here not it's it's much much more dense
and the way these uh the slam framework
works is basically it accumulates
multiple frames of Point cloud
and it corrects for the motion of the
platform and the platform is whatever
the sensor is mounted on it's a robot or
whatever as it moves it collects
multiple frames it registers them
together and by registration I mean it
it undoes the the motion part which will
otherwise blur out your your point Cloud
it registers them all together and uh
basically accumulates all those points
and generates a very dense map of the
environment you can do slime with lidar
with radar with cameras there's you can
you can do it with with many different
sensors it's extremely useful but it
also has its own caveats but so for
instance this one I did it very late at
night so that there was nobody around uh
who was like moving but if you do it you
do did this during the day where like
people are moving around and there's
cyclists what happens is that you would
get Trails for moving
uh
uh Assets in the scene because of course
the the underlying Assumption of the
Islam framework is that everything is
stationary and with a rigid transform
you can register everything to a common
reference frame but if there's Dynamic
Assets in the scene those wouldn't
register and they would they would look
as like these blurred trails
still okay and but that's just a
limitation to note and uh so the point
is you can generate dense almost like HD
like uh uh live maps with your sensors
but you need to accumulate multiple
frames which means it adds some latency
to the to the to the map that is being
generated
um okay so very quickly different
sensors as I said can be used for
robotic mapping sonar is the topic of
discussion for this chapter which stands
for sound navigation and ranging and it
uses ultrasonic uh basically acoustic
waves to sense the environment and
generate the map
there's radar stands for radio detection
and ranging it uses
a radio frequency electromagnetic waves
to sense the environment and basically
generate a 2d or a 3D map then there's
lidar stands for light detection and
ranging that transmits and receives
typically in infrared laser beams and
with that it generates basically a map
of the scene and finally there's a
camera which we're all familiar with it
just collects visible light and and it
it basically constructs images of of the
scene and from those images with some
computer vision techniques you can
generate 3D maps of of the scene so the
first three the sonar radar and lidar
these are called active sensors because
they actively send signals and collect
Back The Echoes from the environment the
signals this could be again ultrasonic
waves radio frequency electromagnetic
waves or Optical electromagnetic waves
so these three are active sensors and
then camera it just collects visible
light from the environment so in that
sense it's not it's not active so
we're going to start with sonar next
time and again you know study the
physics and Signal processing and the
system level analysis and then we talk
about radar and lidar and and cameras I
think this is a good place to quit and
we'll continue next week any questions
all right see you next time